We just threw a lot of terms at you in
that last video, so let's take a closer
look at common metrics and acronyms
used when it comes to advertising.
There are five we'll be exploring,
CPC, CPM, eCPM, CPI and CTR.
Knowing the definitions for each of
these terms is extremely important,
especially as you're evaluating the
success of using ads in your product.
Let's start with CPC or cost per click.
Now, this is essentially
how much an advertiser pays
you if a visitor to your site or a user
of your product clicks on their ad.
The acronym CPM is a little tricky.
This stands for cost per thousand and
the M actually is the Roman numeral for
a thousand.
CPM is how much you earn for
every 1000 views of an add.
This can also be referred to as CPI or
cost per impression,
another item from our list.
eCPM is then the estimated cost per
thousand views and is calculated by
dividing your total revenue by the total
number of views of the ad in thousands.
eCPM is helpful when you're evaluating
the performance of different ads on your
site, and you want to estimate how much
you'll make as the views increase.
Lastly, we come to click-through rate or
CTR, this metric measures how many
users have actually clicked on an ad.
It's calculated by dividing the total
number of clicks by the total number of
impressions or views, and multiplying
that number by 100 to get a percentage.
So now that we've gone through each
of these definitions, let's test your
memory and see if you can remember
these three-letter acronyms.
Fill in the full names for each of these
acronyms using the provided boxes.